uh magnus was winning games was there  ever a moment that it was discussed that  maybe it's time to try something out  with the king's gambit or was that never  a conversation  no king's gambit was never on the agenda  no no i think  i think jan  jan doesn't mind me saying that because  okay it's it's clear that no no i mean  okay you know exactly that magnus team  is ready for the king's gambit and okay  there is there is just no need to to do  this suicidal suicidal things besides  there is also there is that suddenly  magnus shows how to deal with the king's  gambit and then yam will lose all this  mystery heaven whenever he feels that  this is the right moment to use the  king's gambit then people are terrified  but if magnus shows a very comfortable  confident way of dealing with it then  he's paused the fun for the other games